hey guys so I thought it was time for
another X look I haven't done one these
for about a month now and I am trying to
do content more regularly in case you
haven't noticed so um you know this is
this week's video I'm trying to do a
video every week though that is very
much an aspiration not a promise in the
same way that Nicola does it I get the
impression that especially when we go
back into term time that's probably not
going to be possible be fully prepared
me just to take weeks off at random even
out of term time because either I feel
like it or I've been away or as was the
case too because ago I got the keys to
our new house so I can't live here which
is university halls and I have done for
the past a year but two weeks ago
we picked up the keys to our new house
and I say we because I for the next
hopefully two to three years we'll be
living with a bunch of PhD students in
the math department so we have all moved
out of halls and we're now going into a
proper like family residential house and
we could not be happier about this I
think we're all a bit fed up of living
in holes because hardly there's no one
here at the moment most the people who
live lived here will master students and
so when the academic year was out
they've gone home as PhDs we're around
so it's gonna be nice at the end of the
day to come home and probably carry home
with but also come home to other
students and also students who are in a
similar position to us doing a PhD is
kind of a unique thing and it's going to
be really nice to share the experience
of other people and have I mean we all
hang out a lot of the time now but it's
gonna be really nice to sort of have the
whole home experience as well and I'm so
excited for it of course because we're
PhD students we are much more mature
than we were undergraduate and so when
we moved into our new house we
immediately started installing our
collection of fine literature and I'm
kidding we invented the sport indoor
cricket you see my friend Nick here who
is a peer mathematician who is using the
standard tool of indoor cricket the
plastic shopping block
rules were pretty much non-existent and
it was basically just a bit of a laugh
because we had a completely empty house
and decided to have a bit of fun well
there was nothing in it
this actually evolved into like a
housewarming party where we just invited
a bunch of friends over and we ended up
doing barbecue and it was really nice
because I haven't had my own I say my
own I'm renting my own a house to kind
of do that with you geek you know the
ability to have your own kitchen here in
living room manners
it's pretty nice love it more seriously
though where it's gonna be really nice
to have sort of a proper community of
PhD students because it's a really
interesting mix of work and play and I
feel like the transition for myself
hasn't been quite the same as for most
people I think I probably proportionally
did more work to play than most people
did our undergraduate because I really
did nothing but work and coming here and
just being able to that's you know five
or six whenever you finish in the office
you go home when you can you can do what
you want you don't have to do your
tutorial seats or you don't have to
worry about something you know more
often than not there is something but if
somehow it's not quite the same because
you're not forced to do any of this
because you take everything on
voluntarily it's it's so nice to have
freedom in the evenings so being able to
do that with a bunch of other guys
hopefully are gonna have a lot of stuff
to do in the coming year we're all big
gamers so that's gonna be a big part
this year what the actual works under
the PhD has involved me recently has
been actually really cool so I mentioned
in my last X blog my my work which if
you haven't seen the video go check it
out but basically what I'm doing is
looking at this theory that if you
inject a large amount of mass into the
the middle atmosphere above the polar
region in the North hemisphere say then
that mass acts to squish and to compress
the bottom atmosphere the bit the
atmosphere that we live in called the
troposphere and that produces pressure
and temperature anomalies and what I've
been doing recently is working on a
theoretical model of how that might
occur and basically working with this
hypothesis and saying well let's assume
this is true and if we put this amount
of mass into the upper atmosphere the
middle atmosphere how much of a pressure
and how much for temperature anomaly can
we expect in the lower atmosphere and
actually getting what's called an
analytic solution so it's a proper
equation you don't use it
computer to work it out unfortunately
that's quite difficult as it turns out
it took me about a week or two to
actually formulate the problem properly
and I actually did it about three or
four times I'm just going through and
making sure every step that you're
correct and doing things like
dimensional analysis because once or
twice I did it and I got to the end
result and you do an analysis on it and
say well this side has got units of
Newton's per meter per second squared
but this side's got something completely
different so this can't be right where
have I gone wrong now I've actually got
an equation an equation I actually
tweeted out in the vague hope that
somebody might help you solve it because
when you look at an equation like this
it's it's triggering a few flags like a
few alarms in your head in your head
because it's a third order equation it's
a nonlinear equation and it's a partial
differential equation now any one of
those if you were to look at any
equation if you had one of those things
you think oh that's okay that's gonna be
a bit difficult this has got three so I
shaved my supervisor this this equation
any kind of one so the current
strategies were going to scale that what
I'm doing at the moment so what I'm
doing the moment is actually slightly
more complicated case and that I'm
assuming that you have a cylinder of
error and that the air flows out or I
could flow in and that kind of makes
things quite a bit more complicated
so what I'm now going to consider is
what if you just seal off the cylinder
and if you if you can press it down what
happens to the pressure and temperature
anomalies and obviously that's not a
good model of atmosphere but it's gonna
be really interesting to see how much of
the variability that's observed is
encapsulated in that ready
you know stupidly simple model my
supervisor seems to think that it's
gonna be quite a lot so hopefully quite
soon we'll actually mail to see if he's
right or not outside of academic stuff
though I have also been quite busy most
notably I went to the island of Jersey
in the Channel Islands on a quick
holiday from my girlfriend and it's
pretty much my favorite place in the
whole world because it is home to
Durrell so they're all all more formally
there are a wildlife park is what used
to be jersey zoo but Durrell a named
after Gerald Durrell by the way he
haven't heard of him check him out is an
international charity which is involved
in conservation work and it goes all
around the world and it saves species
from extinction now I mention this in my
life and letters video but basically
conservation has always been a mass
topic for me it's always been something
I've been really quite passionate about
so one of the reasons that went over to
Josie apart from the holiday was to go
to Daraa and get lots of footage because
this year I'm gonna be taking part in
the project for awesome if you don't
know what that is that is YouTube's
annual charity giveth on basically where
youtubers are invited to make videos
about their charity of choice and for me
it's going to be dull and I am gonna be
plugging this like nobody's business
because this really really matters to me
the footage you see now is some of the
animals that they have at their all and
pretty much everything you're seeing is
critically endangered and I'm gonna go
about this in the future but you know
please keep an eye out for this video
this really really means a lot to me the
other thing which when doing outside of
work a lot of course is these some
Peters videos so I'm making a whole
bunch of videos from my old college in
Oxford one of the things which the
college gave me to compensate me for
making the videos was a GoPro and I
showed you it in my last egg vlog but
what you're looking at right now is a
product of that GoPros so one of the
things that everybody goes on about with
these cameras is the fact that they're
so good for sports and you can mount
them on even go skydiving all that but
for something which I didn't really hear
mentioned at all until they actually got
one was the ability to do time-lapse
shots so this is shot with my GoPro and
I'm using a piece of software called
panel apps I've linked to in the
description you can simulate the
movement of the camera so the GoPro
actually stayed still and what I'm doing
is I'm tracking across the frame this is
a time-lapse taken from the common room
in my building so this is the view that
we get when we have lunch it's pretty
spectacular
it's benefit of having the campus on top
of the hill and being on top of the tall
building lots of steps to get up to it
but work there at lunch time and lastly
for this video this channel is about to
hit a crazy milestone I mean I about hit
10,000 subscribers on cyber knocks fears
on this YouTube channel I remember when
in 2010 I started this channel and I
edited together
it was terrible video about applying to
Oxford or Cambridge as and on the
university computers I wasn't even on my
computer like I didn't have any editing
software and I counted up the views -
when I got hundred views and I was like
yes I've got a successful YouTube video
that's amazing
and I never imagined that I'd keep doing
it I never imagined that people would
keep watching my videos and here we are
about to hit you know ten thousand
people subscribe to this channel you
know that's ten to the four people but
that's that's ridiculous ten thousand
people is a lot in anybody's book just
talk to the people at Helm's Deep though
anyway thank to thank you guys for being
such an awesome group of people which
which leave really insightful comments
and really supportive of the videos I
make and I you know you guys are just
fantastic so I want to do something to
say thank you so I want to do a 10,000
subscriber video because that's you know
what you do on YouTube please leave in
the comments what you would like me to
do and that could be like a just an FAQ
like just just general questions it
could be a draw my life it could be I
don't know come up with something if
it's not too ridiculous then whatever
some is popular I'm gonna try and do
because frankly it's the least that I
could do q guys 10,000 people
that's that stills not real somehow
thank you for watching guys and
hopefully I'll be seeing you next week
but though I say by your blood eat it
Oh